ich wäre heute aus wie sie der tv
moderatorin jetzt kommen die top 100
charts aus den playlisten der woche viel
spaß meine zuschauer oder zielgruppe ist
ein ganz bunt gemischter haufen aber
eine sache verbindet uns alle liebe ich
meine natürlich die pubertät wenn ich
daran zurückdenke was man alles
durchgemacht hat und was viele
wahrscheinlich auch gerade von euch
durch machen weiß ich nicht was die
natur sich bedankt nochmal dabei gedacht
hat aber wir machen einfach ein wesen
das gerade stehen kann
trauben hat und stück für stück die erde
zerstört ok und wie wäre es wenn dieser
ich nenne ihn jetzt einfach mal mensch
nach zehn jahren so eine phase kommt in
der ist seine eltern hass und haare
unter den achseln bekommt denkt da mal
drüber nach genau so muss es abgelaufen
sein wenn ich mich richtig erinnere hat
meine pubertät somit elf angefangen und
es war die hölle es wuchsen plötzlich
überall haar an dem körper und wenn du
cool sein wolltest dann mussten die auch
sofort wieder weg sein wo ich mir damals
echt jemanden gewünscht hätte der mir
das mit dem rasieren vielleicht ein
bisschen genauer erklären ich erinnere
mich an eine situation die wirklich
seltsam war
eines tages kam ich auf die glorreiche
idee mir die beine zu rasieren mit dem
rasierer meiner schwester ein paar
stunden später sind meiner schwester die
rasierten beine aufgefallen und sie hat
mich darauf angesprochen und was habe
ich getan
auch wieder versprochen ich muss nicht
einmal wenn mich heute mal jemand auf
einem glatten beine ansprechen würde ja
frisch rasiert mit dem biene street
triple klingen womanizer 5000 auch so
glatt aber um mal eine botschaft an alle
mädels und jungs da raus zu senden bei
denen es gerade haarig wird es ist
vollkommen in ordnung und glaubt mir in
ein paar jahren werdet ihr keinen fakt
mehr darauf geben ob da es ist
scheißegal am ende außerdem ist
supermodel werden dann musst du darfst
du kein haar
außer an den augenbrauen und auf dem
kopf haben und den wimpern
da darf auch ich meine guckt euch mal
meine arme an mich hat man früher afl
genannt weil ich durch meine
italienischen gene etwas dunklere haare
haben wenn euch heute mal jemand
nennen sollte dann wirft ihm bitte eine
banane auf dem kopf und sagt schöne
grüße von genießer kommen wir aber zu
einem ganz anderen thema
die periode und der samen akkus beides
passiert euch und nach dem ersten mal
wird es auch nicht aufhören also kommt
damit klappt da habe ich übrigens auch
geholt weil keiner aus meiner familie
nicht vorbereitet hat diese haben sie
niemals das thema aufgegriffen und mich
so darauf vorbereitet vielleicht beim
dritten geburtstag alles gute zum
geburtstag mein schatz und in ein paar
jahren da bist du so richtig aus der
rasse oder bei meinem ersten schultag
viel spaß bei dem ersten schultag schatz
und denkt dran alle kinder lernen lesen
und du blut ist beinahe steinhöfer
ich hoffe man denn das mittlerweile früh
genug in der schule was da so mit dem
körper passiert die ganzen abläufe
ich werde zur frau jetzt kommen wir mal
aber in den punkt warum die pubertät ein
richtiges arschloch ist man fängt an
seine eltern für die kleinsten
kleinigkeiten an zu hassen und ich meine
so eine richtigen hass hass auf den
selbst michael buchner night schwere und
ich weiß es gibt leute unter euch die
niemals probleme mit ihren eltern hatten
sich niemals gestritten haben die ich
bei aber meine fresse wie oft ich mich
mit meinen eltern gestritten haben und
nicht so wie heute wo man eher so mit
denen diskutiert war mama ich kann meine
miete zahle ich habe die blumen gegossen
die müssen so schlaff herunter hängen
das ist so bei der rasse hättest du mir
mal kochen beigebracht dann müsste ich
nicht immer pizza bestellen
damals wurde sich noch so richtig schön
ins gesicht angeschrieben einmal mit 14
auf eine party wollte die erst um 21 uhr
anfängt und bei der zu 100 prozent
alkohol getrunken wurde keine ahnung
warum meine eltern nicht wollten dass
ich da hingehe das ist noch so ein punkt
die pubertären hormone geben uns das
gefühl dass wir die welt komplett
verstanden haben ich kann es nicht mal
heute von mir behaupten zu verstehen
warum ich auf diesem planet bin aber mit
14 mann kennt alle fakten die man fürs
leben brauteltern sind scheiße und
spieße lehrer haben kein privatleben die
besten freunde sind alles was du im
leben braucht alkohol es cool und man
ist immer irgendjemanden unsterblich
verliebt ich merke sie an einem tagebuch
in wenig nicht alles schon so
unsterblich
so tief und mit ganzen kerzen verliebt
aber wenn ich mich daran zurück erinnere
dann habe ich das auch immer genau so
gefühlt das war so richtig so richtig
tiefe liebe und konnte sich auf nichts
anderes mehr konzentrieren und dann hat
die ganze pause damit beschäftigt immer
in der nähe seines schwarms zu sein und
da erwische ich wahrscheinlich ein paar
von euch ne wer hängt in der pause immer
in der nähe von dem schwarm ab und
beobachtet ihn ja ja ich bin wer endet
das ist aber okay denn das ist wirklich
die einzige zeit in der man das noch
legal machen kann wenn du in meinem
alter anfängst menschen zu stoppen dann
kann da auch mal ganz schnell eine
einstweilige verfügung um die ecke
kommen channing tatum ich hab dich nur
beim tus beobachtet so und was will ich
euch jetzt mit diesem video sagen das
weiß ich auch noch nicht ganz so genau
ich glaube ich hätte es damals einfach
schön gefunden wenn jemand der mir
sympathisch ist gesagt hätte haye alles
in ordnung wir haben alle die gleiche
scheiße durch das wird nicht alles so
für immer bleiben und glaubt mir du
wirst ich noch was verändern wenn du
heute schüchtern willst kann es sein
dass du später nicht schüchtern bist
wenn du heute foul willst kann es sein
dass du trotzdem tolles studium oder
sonstwas schaffst die zeit alles
verändert sich und hört bloß nicht auf
diesen blöden satz der sich voll
verändert gut verändert euch alles gut
gefallen uns ständig das ganze universum
verändert sich das ist niemals zum
stillstand gekommen denn stillstand ist
doof und da kommen noch ganz andere
phasen im leben wohl noch ganz andere
probleme hat
ich frage mich manchmal was so ein
40-jähriger über meine generation sagen
würde beziehungsweise über mein alter
erreicht macht ja grund mal dazu ein
video werden wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten video wenn ich nicht über sah
markus spreche oder doch man weiß es
nicht ihr erfahrt es nur wenn nämlich
abonniert also tut es jetzt bis dahin
uk schon klasse